did you find anything
the wha's visit to wuhan ground zero for
covert 19
was tightly controlled by chinese
authorities
and the scientists had stuck to a
consistent narrative about the
possibility of the virus
leaking from a chinese lab in the
official report
published today they repeated that view
lab accidents of course too happens
once in a while we've seen that
throughout history
in many places but we haven't seen or
been able to
uh to to to hear or see
or look at anything that would uh
warrant a different conclusion from our
side
the head of the who took his own
organization's report
and effectively set it on fire dr tedros
said
i do not believe that this assessment
was extensive enough
further data and studies will be needed
to reach more robust conclusions
although the team has concluded that a
laboratory leak is the least likely
hypothesis
this requires further investigation
potentially with
additional missions involving specialist
experts which i am ready to deploy
dr tedros also said chinese authorities
had not shared data in a sufficiently
timely and comprehensive way
it was a remarkable about turn for an
organization that has been accused of
going too easy on china
in the early days of the pandemic ahead
of the publication of the report
one member of the who team who visited
wuhan defended their approach
do you think it was ever going to be
able for to fully trust
that the authorities were being as full
and transparent as possible with your
team whilst of course
we didn't go in with our eyes shut we're
aware of that context
what we did was to try to go in as
scientists
to talk directly to our scientist
colleague
to look with them at the data that
they've collected
in that context we did
what i think we reasonably could do for
now
the most likely origin of covert 19
remains a theory that it originated in
bats
spread to another as yet unidentified
animal before infecting humans and
leading to an explosive outbreak in
wuhan
the laboratory hypothesis is back in the
mix and that
will infuriate beijing tom cheshire sky
news
beijing